uh sorry I have a question would you  ever get married  in this current  this current version of marriage no  I I'm not gonna lie in this current the  way it's so heavily skewed towards women  I couldn't see myself what version of  marriage could you see us I just told  you man I got a whole contract though no  I'm just saying like it would have to be  like I'm because of the cut and that's  what I'm saying it's because of the you  would be with a woman long term though  oh of course  100 and you would love her right and you  would be very devoted and committed 100  right no but you probably would have a  hard time signing the contract because a  contract a contract does not favor me  and so I believe in love I believe in  companionship I believe in men that the  union between men and women I believe in  all of that yeah but that contract that  you asked me to sign up like the problem  is what are guys like you supposed to do